[Music]  would you let a robot work on your teeth  a Las Vegas dentist is the first to  offer an FDA cleared robotic surgical  system in this country it's called yomi  and it helps Dr Andy Murcia of Discovery  Dental perform Dental implantation now  the robotic arm actually Maneuvers to  the precise location of the implants and  then it eliminates the need for any kind  of unnecessary cutting  before we just go ahead and you know  open it up and look at the bone and be  able to place the implant on an angle  that we think is the right position now  we can actually pre-plan it and place it  exactly what we planned it ahead of time  by the way there is no additional cost  to have implants done by yomi prices  start at about twelve hundred dollars